Good afternoon, everyone, and welcome to our first
New Drugs on the Horizon session of this annual meeting of the AACR
2026. This is always a great session.
I have a few intro slides if we could tee those up.
All right. Looks like everything's working.
That's a good start. A few reminders.
So this session is sponsored by Chemistry and Cancer Research.
We have several sessions throughout the annual meeting.
A couple of special things coming up.
On Monday, we have the Outstanding Achievement in Chemistry for Cancer Research
Award lecture.
This is being received by Dr. Cheryl Arrow Smith, so that'll be an exciting
talk.
And then also Monday evening is our CICR
town hall, and this year we are combining with the Hematologic
Working Group as well. So you may recall this town hall
is a wonderful science immersion as
well as reception with wine and beer .
And so, this is always a good event to attend, help
unwind, talk science, and
network and chat with people.
For the first year ever, the CICR is
sponsoring annual travel awards.
We have eight awardees who are here at the annual meeting.
We'll give them a shout-out at the town hall tomorrow night.
But
these are very deserving young investigators.
And this award is sponsored by your donations, your
and our donations. So the membership and
fellowship of Chemistry and Cancer Research
decided that given the uncertainties in budgets,
and the importance of this conference, that we really wanted to do something to
help out more junior investigators.
So watch for this again next year, and there's a little barcode here if you'd
like to donate. You can also go to the AACR website to donate.
All right. So I wanted to give a little bit of history about the New Drugs on the
Horizon.
This is a flagship scientific series.
As I said, it's sponsored by the Chemistry and Cancer Research Working Group.
And really what these sessions are known for is first
disclosures. So this is an international audience, it's an international
stage, and these are first disclosures of molecules that are early in
development and entering the clinic.
So what we do when we have new molecules is
really try to understand breakthroughs in biology.
What is this telling us about not only the drug, but also the disease?
And of course, what we hope is that many of these will
turn into drugs, ultimately, that are benefiting patients.
So we try to learn from each other as a community, and this is one of the
premier events to do that.
All right. So we have a great session.
I'm going to turn it over to my co-chair, to lead off with the first
introduction.
Thanks, Laurie.
It's a distinct pleasure and privilege to be able to introduce the
first speaker.
If you think about how widespread molecular
glues are now, it's because of the heavy lifting work from
the OGs in the field, and Phil is certainly one of those, so I'm looking forward to
this.
The title of his talk is Development of NEO811, a molecular
glue degrader of ARNT, which is also HIF-1 beta,
with potent single activity in clear cell renal cell carcinoma.
Phil.
Thanks very much, Larry. So, my name is Phil Chamberlain.
I'm co-founder, president, and CEO of a company called Neomorph.
We're based here in San Diego.
Here are my disclosures.
And then this is a summary of the pipeline activity that we have at
Neomorph to date.
And so what we're trying to accomplish at Neomorph is to really take the glue
technology and expand it much more broadly in scope.
The issue with the glue technology at the moment, it has a lot of virtues, but
it's really targeted to a subset of the proteome, and we are trying to
take that technology to the point where it can achieve its full potential and
really cover any protein that you may want to address therapeutically.
And until this point, we've been very coy about disclosing our
pipeline, so it's a really great pleasure to be able to, in this forum,
disclose our lead molecule today.
This is the first molecule from Neomorph to go into the clinic, and this is
NEO811 in clear cell renal cell
carcinoma.
So the reason that we're interested in ccRCC is
summarized on this slide here. We think this is a very clear
opportunity. It's a large indication.
There's more than 50,000 patients a year in the US alone that are
suffering from this disease. And up to 90% of those patients have
a mutation that causes loss of function of a protein called VHL.
And so what you can see in this middle slide here is that
you can have a transforming event whereby VHL loss
stabilizes hypoxia-inducible factor signaling.
So, rather than this being an induced phenomenon, now you have
constitutive expression of the HIFs,
and this drives a transcriptional program, in which case a number of
proteins, including, for example, VEGF, are expressed
aberrantly, and this leads to transformation of these cells.
And so our therapeutic hypothesis is that if we
could address and reverse this constitutive HIF signaling,
you would
capture anti-tumor biology that normal cells would not be
dependent upon. Because in a normal context, cells are not
expressing these proteins.And so if we just zoom in
now on this complex here at the middle,
what you can see is that you have downstream of VHL now
you have this constitutive expression of HIF-1 alpha and HIF-2
alpha.
And these proteins now, before they can start their transcriptional
program, they have to dimerize with this protein called Arnt.
And this is the obligate dimer partner.
These HIF-1 alpha and HIF-2 alpha have no transcriptional activity
without binding to the adaptor proteins.
And so you can imagine
that this is now the key node. It's really the critical feature at the heart of
this pathway. And this is extremely robust biology.
There was just the Nobel Prize awarded to some of the
authors listed in these articles in the bottom corner.
But you can also see that this pathway is now extremely well-validated
clinically.
So
there are a number of approvals for VEGF receptor tyrosine
kinase inhibitors. That includes lenvatinib, cabozantinib.
But more recently, there's also been approvals for these HIF-2 alpha
inhibitors such as belzutifan. And belzutifan,
for example, binds to HIF-2 alpha and disrupts the dimer with
Arnt. And so they're able to block the activity of
this protein. But of course, as we look at this pathway, we're interested now
in the broader effect of this pan-HIF mechanism whereby you would shut down the
entire pathway.
Now, the biology, as I said, is extremely robust, but of course, we wanted to get
this repeated and validated in our own hands.
And this is the work of a pharmacology team led by Jake.
And what you can see is that
in this one validation experiment, they were able to
inducibly suppress the expression of Arnt using an inducible
shRNA. So you can see mice fed normal diet,
and then you have mice on Dox chow, whereby in the
xenograft, upon exposure to Dox, Arnt protein levels were
suppressed, and as a result of that, you have this tumor
regression. And obviously, this was exactly the sort of finding we were
hoping to see, and we were very, very excited by that.
And so Arnt is an attractive target. That's how we felt about this.
But there is a problem with this, and this is a problem that is shared with really
a large proportion of the proteome.
Arnt is a classic undruggable protein.
So it's a transcription factor, so it's buried inside the cell, can't be accessed
with antibodies. You'll see that there's no
catalytic activity. There are no obvious ligand binding pockets.
And if you look at this structure of the protein Arnt bound to HIF-2
alpha, what you'll see is that the biology of Arnt is
mediated by protein-protein or protein-DNA interactions.
So this is an extremely high bar, a classic undruggable.
So it's a great candidate for a glue because of course the glues disregard all of
the conventional rules of drug discovery.
And the problem, of course, is that there was no precedent for a glue degrader for
Arnt.
More than 10 years ago, I came and visited the AACR to discuss this
effort.
There is a way of navigating
prospectively target space through this degron approach, and we
helped define the first degron in this work from
2016. And what you can do with these is you can find structural features in
neo-substrate proteins, and you can map them.
And for the cereblon system, we have this G loop that enables you to prospectively
annotate
potential neo-substrates. We looked for this feature, and we couldn't find this
feature either. So that wasn't found in any of the experimental structures, and it
wasn't found in any of the predicted structures that were available either.
But we did have one positive indication.
And so Neomorph was founded with a collaboration with the Center for
Protein Degradation at the Dana-Farber Cancer Institute.
The CPD was co-founded by Eric Fischer and Nathaniel Gray, and it was
led by Lynn Jones. And what we saw from this
collaboration was that while working on a different transcription factor, there
was evidence from proteomics that Arnt could be downregulated.
And so this was obviously a heartwarming finding at the stage of the
project.
And so at Neomorph, we wanted to have a really comprehensive survey
for potential glue chemical matter for this target.
And so what we did is we did a multi-pronged,
very extensive screening effort.
And so there is a cellular degradation screen is shown on the left.
In the middle, we have this ternary complex formation DEL
screening approach that we developed in-house.
And that enables you to directly discover glue candidates from a DEL
approach. And then obviously, we continued with our aggressive
profiling of our chemical matter by proteomics.
And all of this chemical matter then fed into a hit validation workflow, a
mechanism of action elaboration.
And I'm just showing some of the Neomorph scientific
managers on the right that really shouldered with their teams the
heavy lift in getting this project enabled.
I'm just going to show you one example of the types of validation work that we do
for these more complex drug discovery systems.
And so we're huge fans of reconstituting these systems in their entirety, and
that really teaches you that you have control and a good understanding of the
system. And so you can see here that our teams were able
to purify cereblon and DDB1. So we had evidence that these molecules were
mediating their glue activity through cereblon.
They've also purified Arnt, and then with all of the other components that are
required for ubiquitin transfer towards these target
proteins, they've reconstituted the system.
And you can see that in a manner that is dependent both on cereblon
and upon the cognate glue, you get robust ubiquitin transfer
onto Arnt in this reconstituted
system.This tells us that we have a good
understanding of the way that these molecules are fitting together, and it's shown
by this cartoon on the left here.
So you have your glue and your scaffolding, this protein-protein interaction with
the ARNT protein, but we weren't clear on how.
And also this information is not a resolution that is sufficient to support
a structure-based drug design campaign.
And so our Cryo-EM team, led by Andres,
solved the high-resolution ternary complex structure of this system, and there
were a number of really exciting surprises.
So I'm just going to show what happens when this protein docks onto the
surface of cereblon in a manner that's dependent upon the glue.
And you can see that in contrast to really every other literature system for
glues out there, what we're dealing with here is a very, very large
conformational change. And actually, we're seeing a surface, a protein-protein
interaction that is mediated by more than one domain.
So this is really conceptually very interesting for the glue
field. What we're dealing with here is an induced degron.
And of course, the fact that you can have a protein interface, a
neo-substrate interaction that's mediated by more than one domain means
that you can start to now investigate context-dependent degradation for
glues.
Of course, the key thing with this information is that it was the start of a
very large and involved structure-based drug design campaign,
and a huge amount of this work was shouldered by our chem lead, Jenny, and our
bio lead, Scott, both of whom are giving talks later in the AACR
meeting. You'll see the molecule that came out of this campaign, NEO811, at the
top. You can see it's an extremely potent degrader of ARNT.
You'll also see from the whole cell proteomics that it's very, very clean.
It's more than a log unit of separation from the next proteins that are degraded,
and we don't consider there to be any liability associated with these proteins.
When you go into in vitro assays and you look for the HIF-2A-dependent
target gene suppression, you can see that this molecule is able
to really potently suppress VEGF expression.
So this is the anti-transcriptional effect of our molecule, and you
can see it compares very favorably to the approved drug belcitaban.
The molecule itself has excellent properties and is compatible with oral daily
dosing. And so we went into xenograft experiments with
this regimen, and you can see that we have extremely potent
and robust single-agent tumor regression with this molecule in this
CCRCC model xenograft. And you can see that this happens at very low
doses. So we're very excited to see that.
Now, in contrast to many of the cereblon-based glues, ARNT is
systemically degraded by NEO811 in mice.
And so this is a change to the dogma, but you
can see that even with systemic suppression of this protein, we get
no real changes in body weight. And so this also provides some information that
we may be dealing with a very safe and tolerable mechanism.
Now, of course, what we want to see from our mechanism is broader
activity. We want to see our mechanism work in settings where HIF-2A
inhibitors and other standard of care molecules cannot
operate. And so we investigated some of the literature examples for
these. So the first one is a HIF-2A mutant that has
been reported both pre-clinically and in CCRCC patients.
And this is this mutant G323E. And what we did is we've
engineered this, in this case, this single point mutation into a CCRCC model
that responds very well
normally to belcitaban as well as to NEO811.
And you can see that single point mutation is enough to shut off the activity of
belcitaban completely, whereas we continue to suppress VEGF expression with
NEO811. In vivo, we see the same pattern where
this single point mutation is sufficient to essentially turn off the activity of
belcitaban, whereas we retain full activity.
There was another system that we were really, really interested to investigate with
this pan-HIF mechanism, and that is
systems where HIF-2A isn't necessarily driving the
pro-tumorigenic effects. And so what you can see here is this
model that was identified in Chen et al. in 2016.
They found in the panel of PDX lines that were investigated with a
HIF-2A inhibitor, there was a line, in this case,
XP490, where there was virtually no expression of
HIF-2A, very low expression of HIF-2A, and correspondingly, this
PDX line did not respond well to the HIF-2A inhibitor that they
assayed in that experiment. So we've set up a
collaboration with the Brugarolas Lab at UT Southwestern.
This model is very complex. It requires orthotopic kidney capsule
transplantation followed by tumor
fragmentation and then subcu implantation.
So we're working through these models now, but this model you can see
belcitaban actually had more activity than the analog that was
investigated in Chen et al. But you can see that NEO811 with that broader
anti-HIF mechanism is able to capture additional biology
and have really impressive tumor growth inhibition in this resistant model.
And so, in summary,
we have an opportunity for a differentiated mechanism of
action with ARNT HIF1B molecular glue
degraders. And so screening and structure-based drug design has enabled
us to degrade a new molecular glue target.
This is a classic undruggable. We're obviously delighted to be able to get this
type of target. This is exactly why I wanted to be involved in the
field at the beginning and why I've stuck with it for so long.
We have a molecule that is potent and selective. It's orally available.
It's cereblon based. So there's a really good understanding of how these molecules
may behave in the clinic.
It drives single-agent tumor regression in CCRCC models, including those that are
resistant and refractory to standard of care, such as HIF-2A
inhibitors. That said, because all of these molecules are
downstream of VHL and they're all in the same pathway, we expect this
is going to be complementary and combinable with other agents in the pathway, and
Scott will present some additional data on that at his poster later in the
meeting.And so, with that, I'll
just say that we're excited to now see that NEO811
has been dosed in patients. We're obviously very early in our clinical trial.
This is in
patients with locally advanced or metastatic non-resectable CCRCC.
And then for more details, obviously, in the interest of time, I had to leave a lot
of information out, but we have Jenny, Scott, and Jake.
They're all presenting posters or presentations Tuesday, and I'd
strongly recommend you go and visit
their presentations.
So with that, I would like to acknowledge the incredible team that we have at
Neomorph. This was our first project.
It was executed while we were building the company.
It obviously took a huge amount of work and effort, and essentially everyone at the
company touched this project in some way.
We have a wonderful set of co-founders, and we're incredibly grateful for the
investors and collaborators that have really shown incredible conviction in
staying with the course with this project and with others.
And with that, I'd like to thank you for your attention, and I'd love to take some
questions.
Okay, for the questions, please go to the microphones, and please
try to keep your questions short so we can get as many in.
Yeah, Frank Lee from WuXi AppTec. Great talk.
So my question is in clinical, so how you monitor your
drug efficacy biomarker? Because it's
downstream of HR2F. In
CCRCC, there is
red blood cell drop or how you monitor it, like
mechanism-wise?
Yeah. So, there's a few things there.
So,
anemia is an on-target
consequence of therapeutic intervention in this
pathway.
People have done incredible clinical work already in showing how you can
monitor and rescue that effect, for example, with the administration
of erythropoietin.
So, we don't expect that our mechanism is going to avoid the
well-established consequences such as anemia, but we believe that
these are easily monitorable and
manageable. And then the other part of that is the biomarker strategy.
We'll be disclosing this data at a later date, but of course, glues are
extremely privileged. Actually, degraders, in general, are extremely
privileged because you are actually with
even the first dose of your therapeutic, you're depleting a
protein from
a patient and that's
more than probably any other modality.
It's possible to monitor and know that you had your
on-target effect very, very early in a clinical development effort.
Thank you very much.
Yeah. Very nice talk. Thank you.
Does ARNT
show any weak interaction with cereblon, or is it 100% dependent
upon the presence of the glue?
Yeah. So, there's been some discussion about this in
the glue and proximity field, whether all of the proteins
that are degraded with therapeutic
glues have some kind of background affinity already, and you're just
potentiating that with the therapeutic.
I think the model that I've worked on
for the last
15 years or so is more towards the true
neomorphic neo-substrate model.
Of course, we've looked for these kind of things.
We don't really see any significant background binding in a lot of systems.
And
the potency level, it doesn't really support
ruling that out, right? So,
just the sheer diversity
of recruitment modes that you can have to one ligase makes it seem unlikely that
all of these things are, to some extent, endogenous binders, and with different
chemical matter, you can recruit them.
And I'd also say that it's actually very, very difficult to measure that because
we're talking about proteins will have some measurable binding to each other,
and
there's really no method that can work substantially above micromolar.
So, it's very hard to know, but the model that has worked very well for us is
treating these things as true neomorphic neo-substrates.
Thank you for the wonderful talk, and congratulations for
building the plane while you're flying it.
My question is about in the
XP490 PDX model where the
IF2 alpha was not present, your molecule was still active in that
model. It's fantastic that you can show your differentiation compared to
the inhibitor. But my question is more about what is the mechanism of action
in this model system? How does it work?
Well, so we could hypothesize, we haven't actually
proven this yet, but it seems likely that with the pan-HIF
mechanism, we're suppressing HIF2,
and then we also are suppressing HIF1 signaling as well, as well as some
other proteins, too. And so for these CCRCC
models where they have lost VHL, but they have very, very low levels of
HIF-2 alpha, you could imagine that perhaps HIF1 alpha
is contributing to the pathology.
And of course, with ARNT, we're capturing all of that biology.
So,
clearly, there was enough HIF-2 alpha residual in that
system for belzetifan to have some effect, but there's clearly
additional biology where this pan-HIF mechanism can provide
benefit.
Thank you.
I think we have time for one more quick question. Over here.
Okay. Thank you for a brilliant talk. This is John from Degron Therapeutics.
So, could you please further explain how you use the cryo-EM
structure to guide your drug design?
Yes. So,
we have an incredibly talented structural biology team.
We have ternary complex structures for every system we work on, usually
within months of initiation.
From there,
glue optimization isObviously, this
is quite well known. It's challenging compared to standard
optimization of binary systems, but there are good biophysical reasons for that.
And with that understanding, what we've built out is an expert med
chem team that can interpret that and
improve our molecules. If you're interested in that, Jenny Griffin is going to be
giving a talk on Tuesday, and that's focusing entirely around the structure-based
drug design story.
Okay. Thank you.
Okay, let's thank Phil again for a great talk.
Thank you.
All right. It's my pleasure to introduce Dr.
Suzanne Sitnikova,
who is a cancer immunologist and a director in the discovery
team that's focused on immune cell engagers at AstraZeneca.
Suzanne will present on AZD8359, a novel
CD8-based T-cell engager designed to deliver a
wide therapeutic window in prostate cancer. Welcome, Suzanne.
Thank you so much, and thanks for the organizers for inviting me here to talk to
you about another modality that's also very exciting and showing
some great promise in prostate cancer.
So as you all know, the success of immune checkpoint blockade has
really proven that the immune system can be a very powerful ally in the fight
against cancer. But that approach does require
pre-existing anti-tumor immune responses.
So for indications like prostate cancer that don't tend to elicit strong
anti-tumor immune responses, the benefit of immune checkpoint
blockade has been typically quite limited.
So this is where a new modality, T-cell engagers, or TCEs,
could really deliver transformative potential in the clinic.
And this is because TCEs can drive what we call synthetic
immunity. And that's when the T-cell can kill the
tumor cell in the absence of the endogenous
TCR-MHC recognition process that normally dictates
T-cell responses.
So how do TCEs do this? Well, TCEs are multi-specific
antibodies, so they combine to both the T-cell and the tumor cell,
and that brings those two cell types together into close contact so they can form
an immune synapse, and this triggers the tumor cell killing.
And so early clinical data with this modality across several indications,
including metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer, have
really shown a great promise. But there are two main challenges that have been
emerging.
The first one is the selection of an optimal tumor-associated antigen
or TAA.
So why is this so critical, and what would make an optimal TAA?
Well, the TCE will deliver a strong cytotoxic
signal to any cells that express the TAA.
So it is very important for an optimal TAA to have minimal
normal tissue expression, so you're limiting the risk of
on-target, off-tumor toxicity. But it's also very
important that the TAA is expressed in sufficient copy number on the
surface of the tumor cells, and also on a large enough proportion of the tumor
cells within a patient to drive deep anti-tumor responses.
To address this challenge, we've identified a novel TAA in prostate
cancer called STEAP2, and we've found that it has limited normal
tissue expression and high homogeneous tumor expression.
So we're very excited about this TAA.
The second challenge that the field is seeing for TCEs
is that really they deliver a very strong immune activation,
and that can lead, in many cases, to what we call cytokine release
syndrome, or CRS. And when that presents at grade three or
above, it can be dose limiting and really prevent efficacious
levels of the TCE being reached in patients.
To address this challenge, we sought to exploit the differential
role of CD8 and CD4 T-cells in anti-tumor immune
responses, by developing the Titan
platform, which is a novel TCE format that preferentially engages
the CD8 T-cells over the CD4s, and that allows
us to reduce cytokine release while preserving cytotoxic
responses.
So I'll start by telling you a bit about why we're so excited about STEAP2.
STEAP2 is a metalloreductase with a critical role in prostate
biology, but the key attributes of STEAP2 that really make
it an ideal TCE target is that it is expressed on
the surface of prostate adenocarcinoma cells at a higher
level than on normal prostate tissue and at a much higher level than on any
other tissue type.
So when we look at this normal tissue expression, it
really suggests a low risk of on-target, off-tumor
toxicity.
When we compare that to PSMA, which is a clinically validated
prostate TAA, we see a much cleaner normal tissue expression
profile for STEAP2 with reduced surface expression on several
organs, including ones that have been shown to be
involved in
toxicities induced by PSMA-targeted therapeutics, such as the
intestine and the salivary gland.
When we then look at the prevalence of STEAP2 on lesions from
metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer, what we can see
is that virtually all lesions have most cells expressing
STEAP2. That's in the red and the orange bars.
And this type of expression profile is also conserved across all
stages of the disease and all metastatic sites.
If we compare now staying those lesions for PSMA, what you
can see is there's a much larger proportion of lesions where very few cells express
PSMA, shown in the blue.
And we know that the density and the homogeneity of TAA expression
is a key determinant of TCE anti-tumor activity.
So this expression profile of STEAP2 is really very promising and
aligns quite closely to what we'd want from an ideal TCE
target.So to
address the second challenge that I was mentioning, which is the incidence of
high-grade cytokine release syndrome.
Here we're really looking to use this CD8 guided format.
And why do we think that CD8 guidance could help with this?
Well, here we're really looking at a differential role between CD8 T cells and
CD4 T cells in the response to a conventional, here
non-CD8 guided T cell engager. And what you can see is that
when we culture tumor cells with either purified CD8
or CD4 T cells, they have a very different response, with the
purified CD8s being more cytotoxic but producing
less cytokines than the purified CD4s.
Similarly, if we look in vivo in our humanized mouse models, if we
deplete the CD4 T cells, we see a significant reduction in the amount of
cytokine release that we get after TCE treatment.
That doesn't happen if we deplete the CD8 T cells.
So these data really support the hypothesis of
incorporating a CD8 bias into our TCEs to really
capitalize on that cytotoxic activity of the CD8 T
cells and reduce the cytokine producing activity of the
CD4 T cells.
So what does a TCE that can do that look like?
Well, here's a schematic of AZD8359, and as you can
see it has bivalent targeting of the STIP2
TAA,
which was selected based on its expression profile to deliver both potent
antitumor activity and a reduced risk of on-target off-tumor
toxicity.
It also incorporates the CD8 binding domain, which is our guiding arm
that biases the activity towards the CD8 T cells, which are the main
cytotoxic cell type, and away from the CD4s, which are the
main cytokine producing cell type, and they've been identified as key drivers
of CRS.
And finally, it contains a TCR agonist domain to
stimulate the T cells.
So in the next part of my talk, I'll show you a bit of the data we've generated
that underpins the potential for AZD8359
to transform outcomes in the clinic.
So we initially sought to confirm that the design of the TCE was
delivering the anticipated activity.
So we used a STIP2 knockout cell line, to
confirm that the cytotoxicity we're seeing in vitro is indeed STIP2
dependent. And then we generated some tool reagents where
we took out either the TCR engaging arm or the CD8
binding arm. And what we saw is that the
cytotoxicity is entirely dependent on the binding to the TCR.
But actually you can get killing in the absence of the CD8 binding arm,
but that arm does confer a much increased potency to the
final molecule. When we then looked at the activation of the
T cells at the end of these assays, what we could see is that with a conventional
non-CD8-guided TCE, both CD8s and CD4 T cells are
equally activated.
If we treat instead with our CD8 guided TCE,
AZD8359, what we saw was the
anticipated increased activation of CD8 T cells over
CD4 T cells.
And we could also see that with another methodology, so looking at the behavior of
the T cells using live cell imaging.
And what you can see in this video is it allows us to visualize the
CD8 T cell in blue contacting the green tumor cell,
and you can see that they're both bound by the TCE that's shown in purple.
And with these videos, we can quantify the amount of
time that a T cell is in contact with a tumor cell.
And what we saw is that if you treat these cells with a
conventional 2+1 TCE,
both the CD4s and the CD8s equally increase the
amount of time they spend in contact with a tumor cell, likely due to the
formation of immune synapses. However, when we treated
with our CD8 guided TCE, AZD8359,
only the CD8 T cells increased that contact time with the tumor cells
forming those immune synapses. And you can hopefully see that in this
video where the red CD4 T cells are very mobile, but the
blue CD8 T cells are much more often stuck in the vicinity of a tumor,
likely in an immune synapse.
So we're really excited to see this, and we went on to evaluate
AZD8359 in in vivo humanized mouse models.
And what we saw here was very potent activity here in a flank tumor model.
And importantly, that activity was STIP2 dependent, so we saw no
effect of an untargeted isotype control TCE.
But we then sought to increase the physiological relevance of this animal model to
the bone metastasis setting, which is very frequent in late stage
prostate cancer. So we developed an intratubal tumor
model,
and we were able to demonstrate that in that model, AZD8359
could completely clear the tumors in these mice.
So very potent activity we're seeing in vivo.
This was all very promising data, but really it's the next data set that
got us very excited about this molecule.
And that's that we can see in vitro and in vivo that
AZD8359 has a wider preclinical
therapeutic index compared to a conventional non-CD8 guided
TCE.
So here you can see in vitro that the window between the cytotoxic
effect and the cytokine release, so the area shaded in purple,
is much bigger for AZD8359 compared to a standard
2+1 TCE.
And when we look in vivo in our humanized mouse models, if we have dose
levels that give the same amount of antitumor activity,
AZD8359 leads to significantly less cytokine
release in these animals after treatment compared to a conventional
non-CD8 guided TCE.So this data really supports
the hypothesis that CD8 guidance can deliver potent
antitumor activity, but with reduced cytokine release and
therefore potentially a reduced risk of CRS in the clinic.
So for the final part of my talk, I'd just like to broaden the view a bit more
just beyond AZD8359.
We know that the format of a TCE is critical in how it
binds to its multiple targets, how it brings the tumor cell and the T cell
together to form an effective immune synapse.
So we've been exploring the impact of a TCE
format on how effectively we can redirect CD8 T cells
to kill tumor cells.
And here what you can see are two molecules that we've characterized preclinically
to target STING2, AZD6621 and
AZD8359, and they differ both in their stimulation domain
but also in their geometry, with the CD8 binding arm being in the
hinge of the titan format that's used for
AZD8359.
What was really encouraging though, is we found that multiple formats can deliver
the CD8 guidance. So when we put these two molecules into our
preclinical assays, they look extremely similar.
Both of them are able to deliver a similarly improved
in vitro therapeutic index compared to a conventional
non-CD8-guided TCE.
And when they're put into in vivo assays at matched
efficacious dose levels, both of those molecules are able to
significantly reduce the cytokine release seen in those animals.
So really supporting the hypothesis that both of these formats
could deliver optimal CD8 guidance preclinically, and so they
both represent two promising shots on goal for our
pursuit of a TCE with a wider therapeutic index in
metastatic castration-resistant prostate cancer.
So really, we are doubling down on next generation
STING2 targeted CD8-guided TCEs to
help unlock the full potential of TCEs in prostate cancer.
Why do we think this approach is so promising?
Because we're tackling the two challenges that are emerging from the clinical
learnings with TCEs, which are firstly, the selection of the optimal
TAA, and here we think that with STING2,
we've really found an ideal target showing high homogeneous
tumor cell expression across all stages of prostate adenocarcinoma
and having limited normal tissue expression to reduce the risk
of on-target, off-tumor toxicity.
And secondly, mitigating the risk of cytokine release syndrome
with a novel CD8-guided format that we have shown to
deliver preferential CD8 T cell engagement, which leads
to potent antitumor activity, but with reduced cytokine
release.
So with that, I'd like to thank the entire AZD8359 team and all of the
supporting team members, and thank you so much for your attention.
Happy to take any questions.
Please go to the microphone for questions. Let's start in the middle.
Hello. Excellent talk. I'm Tiong San from InnoVent. Two quick questions.
Do you think there's a positive impact in term of ADA by focusing on
CD8?
My second question is that by focusing on CD8,
will you be missing out something that derived from the CD4 engagement?
Because on your earlier data, you showed that CD4 does contribute to
antitumor activities. Thank you.
Both very good questions. If I start with the second one, yes,
we've looked into that a lot about whether directing to CD8s
could have any kind of detrimental effect.
But I'd really like to emphasize here that the strategy is to
bias it.
It's not selective. There's not a complete
lack of effect on CD4s, and we definitely also see a bit of
indirect activation of the CD4s. So the CD4s are likely
still able to deliver at the right amount,
the activity that they give. Because when we look in our
preclinical assays, we don't see any detrimental effect, even in
durability, in all sorts of aspects of this
reduced engagement of the CD4s.
And I've forgotten the first half of the question, sorry.
ADA.
Oh, ADA.
So ADA generation, unfortunately, preclinical models are not very good at
predicting accurately how ADA
will be in patients. So I think we'll have to find that one out in
the clinic. But we've not had any red flags in anything we've been doing that
suggests that biasing to the CD8s is increasing our ADA risk.
I'm more thinking about reducing though.
Oh, reducing? No.
Thank you.
Over here.
Yeah. Great talk. I have two questions right here.
First thing is that if you do in your humanized mouse model,
do you still see CD4 being recruited to the tumor
or only see CD8 being recruited to the tumor?
So we see both being recruited, but there is a differential in
the expansion. The CD8s are expanded to a much greater extent
in the tumor setting than the CD4s. Yes.
So the second question to follow up with that, because it's being shown
that CD4, CD8, and tumor cell form this
triad will prevent the exhaustion process.
So have you looked at it, if your long-term protection effect
of your T cell engager only engage CD8 versus
2+1?
Yes. So those are the studies I was
alluding to earlier. We have done durability studies to see if there was any
detrimental effect of the CD8 guidance. We've not detected any.
It's likely due to the fact that there's still indirect engagement to
a lesser extent of the CD4s that seems to be
delivering sufficiently
on what they do to preserve the durability.
But it's a good question. Yeah.The center?
I can't see anything.
Have you done any comparison to detuned CD3 affinity
binders or any comparison of the Sineo Bio
binder that you guys acquired?
Sorry, did we do any comparisons?
Detuned, like the comparison of this strategy to detuned or lower affinity
CD3 binders.
Oh, yes. Affinity reduced CD3 binders.
Yes, so all of those strategies were evaluated in what we're developing when we're
trying to develop the
optimal CD8 guided formats. So for example, the other format I
mentioned, the AZD6621, does include an affinity reduced
CD3. And the affinity of the TCR agonist we have in this molecule is
also quite low compared to ones that have been used pre-clinically
before. So yes, definitely incorporating that rather
than
comparing directly to it.
Thank you.
No worries.
Here on the left. Hello. Thank you very much for the very
interesting talk.
So I have a question. I'm a bit puzzled because we learned in immunology textbooks
that CD4 helper T cells are important for cytokine release
and T cell priming and activation, and also engagement through
TCR with signal one only T cells go into anergy and
eventually will die. So can you comment why in this approach we
didn't see any sort of T cell anergy or exhaustion
with just engaging CD8 positive T cells without the helper T cells and only
with signal one without co-stimulation?
Likely, as I was mentioning, there is still indirect activation of the
CD4 T cells. We don't see them have no change.
We just see that the magnitude of it, rather than being
probably
excessive to what we'd want when you have a normal non-CD8
guided approach and therefore leading to CRS,
we're getting a minimized amount of CD4 activation, which is
sufficient to obviously drive out the killing and the help that the
CD8s need, but not quite as much to drive up that
immune activation and the CRS.
So it's not touching the CD4s. It's just biased to
the CD8s.
And for co-stimulation, do you think it's needed for bispecific T-cell
engagers? Because so far it has been shown that they can
effectively kill. So what's your opinion on co-stimulation as well?
Yeah. Clearly they can
effectively kill, as you say, in the absence of co-stimulation.
I think where co-stimulation will come into play is likely in the durability of the
response. If we're seeing if the clinical learnings do confirm that
over time the TC is losing its effect due to
exhaustion of the T cells or changes in the immune milieu, and that's where
co-stim, and I know it's being actively investigated
in several trials, could deliver a huge benefit in terms of
durability.
Thank you very much.
Over here.
Yeah, I have two questions. For your CD8 bia
targeting, is that CD8 alpha or CD8 beta?
The second question, do you think there's any difference between CD8
alpha and beta targeting?
Is it specific to CD8 alpha or beta?
Yes. To alpha.
The binder is an alpha binder. I didn't catch the second.
And then are there any differences with alpha versus beta?
Oh, yes. Well, obviously the cell types that it could direct to could be different
based on the expression profile of CD8 alpha and beta.
Thank you.
Okay. Final question over on the side.
Great talk. Thank you. Mahesh from UMD.
So does your CD8 guiding arm only has
capability
towards just guiding CD8 T cells or does it have any additional function?
No, we do consider it as likely an anchor arm.
It guides, it doesn't have functionalities.
You saw with those molecules where the CD8
was removed. It seems to also increase the potency of the molecule,
likely via the anchoring function that increases the avidity effect on the
TCR binding.
Okay. Thank you.
All right. Let's thank Suzanne again.
Okay, back to molecular glues. Our next speaker is Dr.
Hillary Nicholson
from Tango Therapeutics, and she's going to present on TNG961, a
selective oral molecular glue degrader of HBS1L for the
treatment of FOCAD deficient cancers.
Good afternoon. Here are my disclosures.
Tango Therapeutics is a clinical stage oncology company
with our most advanced molecule, the PRMT5 inhibitor
volapemedostat and its brain penetrant counterpart,
TNG456, currently in clinic for the treatment of MTAP
deleted cancers. We have a vested interest in the chromosome
9p21 deleted space, and today I'll speak to you about
TNG961, an HBS1L molecular glue degrader
being developed for the treatment of FOCAD deleted cancers, all of which are
co-deleted for MTAP.
Chromosome 9p21 loss is a common event in cancer,
with the deletion centering on the CDKN2A tumor suppressor
gene. Adjacent to CDKN2A is MTAP, whose
loss creates a dependency on PRMT5.
Telomeric to MTAP is the FOCAD gene, whose loss creates a dependency on
HBS1L. And we first identified this synthetic lethal
interaction back in 2022 with a genome-wide CRISPR screen in
FOCAD isogenic cell lines, where HBS1L came out as our
top hit in FOCAD negative cells compared to FOCAD proficient
cells. And we also pulled out a strong hit in Pelo, which is a requisite
binding partner for HBS1L.
HBS1L and FOCAD both play roles in the maintenance of
translational homeostasis, where during the course of normal
translation, ribosomes can become stalled on aberrant mRNAs.
And those ribosomes can be rescued by the HBS1L-Pelo ribosome
rescue complex, and the aberrant mRNA can then be
degraded starting with the SKI complex, which is stabilized by
FOCAD.In the absence of focad, as
from chromosome 9p21 deletion, this creates a dependency
on HBS1L for that ribosome rescue to proceed with normal
translation.
And in this colony formation assay in MiaPaCa2
pancreatic cancer cells, which are co-deleted for focad and MTAP,
you can see on the top row where focad is negative, but HBS1L is
intact, robust colonies can form.
But in the bottom row, when focad is inactivated and HBS1L is
withdrawn, no colonies can form, demonstrating the strength of that
synthetic lethal interaction.
We therefore sought to develop a molecule that could inactivate
HBS1L with the hypothesis that loss of HBS1L in the
focad-negative context could lead to activation of ER
stress, the unfolded protein response, and subsequently loss of viability.
We decided to start with a molecular glue degrader approach as
HBS1L has structural similarity to NEO substrates.
To identify starting material for a medicinal chemistry campaign, we
conducted parallel biochemical and cellular screens.
For our cellular screen, we knocked a HiBit tag into the endogenous
HBS1L locus so that we could monitor endogenous protein level.
And we counter-screened against GSPT1 HiBit knock-in cells, as
GSPT1 is a paralog of HBS1L and also a common NEO
substrate of IMID-based molecular glue degraders.
For our
biochemical screen, we used an HTRF-based induced proximity
assay to monitor the complex formation between HBS1L,
ceruloplasmin, and compound. And again, here we counter-screened against
GSPT1.
We identified TNG-6266 as a weak but
HBS1L selective hit from this screen.
An exciting development was achieved when we solved the cryo-EM
structure for this molecule, TNG-4857, which
improved degradation potency over our screen hit by a thousandfold
and picked up a cellular assay as
well.
This molecule retains selectivity over GSPT1, and with this
cryo-EM structure in hand, we were able to test hypotheses
such as the cyclization of the orthofluorobenzamide
ring in 4857, and we synthesized multiple six-six
bicyclic ring structures with surprising increases in
HBS1L potency and unpredictable GSPT1 activity.
Here you can see TNG-7535, which retains the
nitrogen and carbonyl moieties of 4857 but is now cyclized by the
addition of the atoms highlighted in orange.
7535 further improves degradation potency and cell
viability potency, but now picks up activity against
GSPT1 in the single-digit nanomolar range.
TNG-7326 is the naphthyl-matched pair to
4857 and further drives degradation potency for
HBS1L into the picomolar range with single-digit activity in our cell
viability assay and is now clean against GSPT1.
Further med chem led us to TNG-961, shown here
in 2D and also zoomed in here on the solved
cryo-EM structure to allow us to highlight some of the molecular
interactions that drive ternary complex formation.
You can see here, in addition to the canonical
glutarimide nitrogen participating in a hydrogen bond to peripheral
ceruloplasmin, you can also see the urea moiety up here for
TNG-961 participating in hydrogen bonding to
ceruloplasmin glutamate 377 and histidine 353.
In addition, glutamate 377 and serine
375 over here participate in a bifurcated hydrogen bond to
arginine 664. And that region also creates a
pocket that accepts the gem-dimethyl group of TNG-961.
To investigate the activity of the molecule, we started with Western blotting for
HBS1L and a panel of common NEO substrates for molecular
glue degraders. And in this Western blot, you can see that after six hours of
treatment with TNG-961 in MM1S cells, we saw
efficient degradation of HBS1L without comparable
activity at any of the NEO substrates we tested.
Expanding that out to the whole proteome, we used those MM1S cells,
and after six hours of treatment, our MS-based global proteomic
study showed exquisite selectivity for HBS1L out of the entire
proteome. And that selectivity then translated into our cell
viability assay here using focad isogenic cell line pairs from
five distinct lineages, showing a hundredfold selectivity for the
focad-negative cells over their focad intact counterparts.
In vivo, TNG-961 dosing led to
increases in exposure that were dose proportional and also
degradation of HBS1L in terminal PD tissues.
Consistent with that degradation in tumor tissue, we also
observed strong efficacy in four different
CDX models from three different lineages, all of which are focad
deleted.
We also observed strong regressions and complete regressions
in pancreatic cancer and non-small cell lung cancer models, both of
which represent areas of high unmet medical need.
As all focad-deleted tumors are co-deleted for MTAP, we
also wanted to ask whether there might be non-overlapping sensitivity
between TNG-961 and MTA-cooperative PRMT5 inhibitors.
We used the MiaPaCa2 CDX model for this, which is co-deleted for focad and
MTAP and has previously been shown to be refractory to
MTA-cooperative PRMT5 inhibitors.
Here shown in blue using our PRMT5 inhibitor, volapametostat, you initially
can see some tumor stasis followed by tumor outgrowth.
And in gray, you can see that this model is highly responsive to
TNG-961, which can induce rapid and complete
regressions.In the red, we initially treated with our
PRMT5 inhibitor, and then when tumor outgrowth was apparent, we switched to
treatment with TNG961, at which point all tumors began to
regress. And these data indicate that there's non-overlapping
sensitivity between TNG961 and the MTA cooperative PRMT5
inhibitors, as well as non-overlapping mechanisms of resistance.
These data also led us to test the direct combination of
TNG961 and MTA cooperative PRMT5 inhibitors.
Here we used the NCI-H838 non-small cell lung cancer
cell line, which is again focad and MTAP co-deleted.
And using subtherapeutic doses of TNG961 and
vepimetostat, you can see a clear combination benefit here in red,
with all tumors regressing and six out of eight tumors reaching complete
regression.
Mechanistically, TNG961 leads to
a decrease in pyrimycin incorporation into actively
translated proteins, shown here exclusively in the
focad-negative cells, and we don't see a comparable response in the
focad-proficient cells.
In the middle, using IFRD1 as a canonical marker of the
ER stress response, you can see that focad-negative cells induce
IFRD1 in response to TNG961 treatment, and there is no comparable
response in the focad reconstituted cells, despite efficient
HBS1L degradation.
And then looking in the third panel at the downstream transcriptional response
characteristic of the unfolded protein response, again, we
observe dose-dependent increases in CHOP, Trib3, and GADD34
mRNA transcripts exclusively in the focad-negative cells,
but not in the focad-proficient counterparts.
And taken together, these data demonstrate a mechanism that is
exclusive to the focad-negative context.
We conducted 14 and 28-day safety toxicology studies
and saw a favorable safety profile for TNG961.
And we achieved exposures 20-fold above our human predicted
efficacious dose.
And we looked at terminal PD tissues from our 14-day study and
saw degradation of HBS1L and subsequent destabilization of
Pelo in all tissues and at all doses tested.
Here I'm showing you the
data from blood, which also suggests the possibility of
peripheral PD monitoring in clinic.
Bringing it together, you can see that TNG961 has all the attributes
to support its selection as a development candidate.
TNG961 is a single enantiomer glutarimide-based molecular glue
degrader of HBS1L with excellent biochemical and
cellular potency. And our in vivo efficacy data,
in vitro data, and cross-species in vivo PK support its further
development.
We see a broad clinical development opportunity for using
TNG961 to treat all focad-deleted cancers, which
encompass 4% of all human cancers and 5% of
non-small cell lung cancer.
We see the opportunity for indication expansion into an additional 2% of
cancers which have SKI complex impairment beyond focad.
And we anticipate clinical activity as monotherapy, as well
as we have observed combination benefit with PRMT5
inhibitors.
TNG961 is an IND-ready oral potent selective HBS1L
degrader for the treatment of those focad-deleted cancers, which are a third of the
MTAP-deleted population.
Our GLP toxicology studies support its advancement into first-in-human,
and our exposures support a first-in-human starting dose within the
efficacious range.
We have an enabled formulation that we used in our GLP tox studies and
that is ready for clinic, and we anticipate our strong monotherapy activity with
also the opportunity to combine with PRMT5 inhibitors.
And with that, I'd like to thank the entire team at Tango for their
collaboration and contributions in support of this work, as well
as our CRO partners and AACR and CICR for giving me the
opportunity to speak to you today about TNG961.
I'd also like to highlight the QR code here, which can take you
to our co-publication of TNG961 coming up
right now in "Cancer Discovery" and our three additional posters
that highlight some of the exciting work going on at Tango beyond TNG961.
And I'll be happy to take any questions.
So for questions, please go to the microphones.
Over here in the center.
Thank you for the nice presentation.
So
what are the biomarkers that you plan to use for the clinical
studies?
Yeah, I think
we have shown that HBS1L can be a biomarker
for its own degradation. Also, the
destabilization of Pelo that comes subsequent to HBS1L
loss,
those can be used downstream, and we're still doing a lot of translational
biology to identify additional predictors of response.
Thank you.
Over on the right.
Can you comment on whether all focad-deleted cell lines
show sensitivity, or whether or not there's varying sensitivity across
lines?
Yeah. Actually, the context is bigger than focad, right?
It's really SKI complex destabilization, and focad is
certainly the largest way to achieve that.
But additional work from Ed Chan and Paquita Vazquez, as well as the
group from AbbVie, have shown that things like TTC37
destabilization can also create that context.
So we generally see a very good correlation between destabilization of SKI complex
and sensitivity to TNG961.
Great talk. Thank you. So your volcano plot showed
pretty efficient degradation of your target.
Really, really high, 10 to the 8th, 10th, and 9th.
But it did show some off-target effects potentially that rose to a level of
significance. I was wondering if you could share a little bit about what those
off-target effects are and potentially whether there's shared biology, which
explains why they go down when you're degrading.
Absolutely. Yeah. So in addition to P less than
.05, .01, pick your favorite significance marker,
in proteomics, we also set a threshold that you needed to have more
than one unique peptide identified and
10% coverage of the protein. All of the other
dots that breached that significance level did not have
more than one unique peptide or 10% coverage.
But also from the QR code, you can see in the manuscript, we've actually
annotated every
protein in that proteomics experiment from that volcano plot, as well
as all of the P values and log fold change for the
entire proteomics data set.
Great. Thank you.
Hi. Duane Demong, Merck Research Labs. Really nice talk.
I had a question about patient selection biomarkers.
You could readily identify MTAP loss.
Are you intending to look for focad loss by
IHC, or?
Yeah, that's a great question because we'd need to find the patients to treat them.
So I think the first part is because a third of the
MTAP-deleted population is co-deleted for
focad, if you enrich for those MTAP-deleted patients, which is becoming
increasingly more routine, you already improve your hit rate to about one in
three.
Beyond that, assaying specifically for focad, of course, whole exome
seq is already there. You can use some commercial panels that don't
have focad but might have genes that flank it, so you could infer a
chromosomal deletion. And then beyond that, certainly we would
love to have a monoclonal antibody for focad to do
IHC. That's not commercially available right now, but there are other
methods such as RNA scope, which could be ready off the shelf for that.
Great. Thank you.
We still have a little bit of time. So, I was going to ask, you showed the
potential for combos with PRMT5. Do you have other
combo ideas in mind, or?
Yeah, thank you. So we certainly anticipate strong monotherapy activity,
and our preclinical data supports that.
We did show the combination with MTA cooperative PRMT5 inhibitors, and that's sort
of a natural fit both for our pipeline and the chromosome 9p
co-deleted space. But the favorable safety profile that we
observed in our GLP safety toxicology studies actually support
combination with pretty much anything.
Standard of care,
the RevMed KRAS inhibitors, draxlarasib in particular, and
I think that you could think about any rational combination,
particularly with an independent genetic context might be a good place
to start for combinations.
Great. Thanks. Oh, one more question over there.
Great talk, Hilary. If I recall correctly, HBS1L
did not emerge as a sensitivity with focad loss in the initial
screening, and I wonder if you could comment to what degree the PELO
degradation is actually important to the mechanism
here.
Sorry. HBS1L
in the first genetic screen we did?
Yeah. Was that also as significant as PELO for
focad loss in sensitivity?
Yeah. So we published a target validation study
earlier this year, which
only identified
PELO, and that's because HBS1L wasn't in that library. It was sub-genomic.
In this CRISPR screen that I showed, this was a genome-wide library,
and HBS1L does come out as the stronger hit.
In our hands, that has always been true.
PELO, of course, would be a strong hit.
There's strong validation work for that.
What we have observed is that PELO
requires being in a complex in order to be stable, and that's also
supported by literature. So in our hands, when we degrade HBS1L,
we always see subsequent degradation of PELO.
Okay. Thank you.
You're welcome.
Thank you.
Okay. Well, let's thank our speaker again.
It's my pleasure to introduce Dr. Shirah Garde from
EpiBiologics,
where she is the chief scientific officer.
She'll be presenting on EPI-326, a novel
mutation-independent and normal tissue-sparing EGFR
bispecific antibody that degrades EGFR for the treatment of
EGFR-driven solid tumors. Welcome, Shirah.
Thank you. I'd like to thank the organizers and particularly the committee for the
new drugs on the horizon and the opportunity to introduce you to
EpiBiologics and our lead clinical candidate,
EPI-326.
I have the following disclosures.
So as we heard about this morning and a little bit even today, targeted
protein degradation is emerging as a really important new
therapeutic modality. We've heard about a lot of the innovations that are
happening within this field. However, the focus of
a lot of this is on targets inside the cell.
This leaves about 40% of the proteome unaddressed.
EpiBiologics was founded to bridge this gap.
We are a bispecific antibody company focused on the degradation
of extracellular soluble and membrane factors.
We have created an atlas of degrading receptors that allows
us to localize the degradation of extracellular targets
to the disease site for both oncology and
immunology. Our first clinical candidate is
EPI-326, which is an EGFR-directed Epitac
that is meant to degrade all forms of pathogenic
EGFR, specifically within the tumor site, and I'll be talking a little bit
about that in a moment.As I
mentioned, Epibiologics is founded based upon innovations out
of Jim Wells' lab. And it's really the concept that we can use a
bispecific antibody and that one arm of the antibody binds to the
pathogenic extracellular target, and the other arm binds to a
degrading receptor that we pull from what we call our EpiAtlas, that
contains over 270 distinct degrading
receptors. This allows us to localize degradation.
It also allows us to degrade either through E3 ligases in the
proteasome or through internalization receptors in the
lysosome.
Similar to other degrading modalities, so PROTACs and molecular
glues, we've been able to demonstrate that we remove the entirety of the
protein and the subsequent scaffolding activity that it supports.
And this is particularly important as we think about EGFR.
Different though, is our ability to localize the degradation,
and we do this through the selection of our degrading receptor from our
EpiAtlas.
Additionally, because we are a bispecific antibody company, we have
prolonged PK and PD effects, which allows us to
drive really strong and durable degradation in vivo,
which is really differentiated from small molecule-based approaches.
Additionally, we are able to co-opt these degrading receptors to remove the
pathogenic target, but they themselves have their own biology.
And this can be synergistic with the removal of that
pathogenic target to increase activity.
So I don't have to introduce EGFR to this audience, but I do want to
highlight that EGFR drives oncogenesis in multiple
forms. So it exists as a mutated form that becomes
hypermutated upon standard care treatment within
non-small cell lung cancer, and it exists in an overexpressed
or amplified wild type form within head and neck and CRC
cancers. Additionally, it is a heterodimer partner for other
ERBB family members, particularly HER2 and HER3,
and can support their oncogenic signaling as well.
Currently, there really are no therapeutics that can go after all these different
forms of EGFR, and that's really important because it limits their
ability to go into different EGFR-responsive tumor types.
Our ability to degrade EGFR agnostic to the form opens up the
potential to work within non-small cell lung cancer, head and neck, and
CRC.
Additionally, molecules that are currently in the clinic that go after EGFR
inhibit signaling within the tumor,
but they also inhibit signaling within healthy tissue, and
this leads to on-target, off-tumor toxicities that
are dose-limiting. This is bad for patients, but it
also prevents these molecules being able to be dosed high enough and
long enough to drive really strong and durable anti-tumor
activity.
EPI-326 was designed to be able to degrade all
oncogenic forms of EGFR, but to do this in a localized
manner to the tumor to drive increased
safety as well as activity.
So with this in mind, the team started by looking at our EpiAtlas and
identified degrading receptors that were enriched in
EGFR-responsive tumor types, but that had limited expression within the
healthy tissues. They also ensured that the expression of our
degrading receptors were in the same cells as EGFR, so were co-localized
on the cells, both at the single-cell level by RNA, but
also by IHC.
Through this evaluation, we identified a degrading receptor that had the
key properties that we were looking for.
So our degrading receptor is integrin beta 6, and it is able
to drive deep and durable degradation of EGFR in the
tumors. Additionally, it had the expression profile that we
wanted. It has very limited normal tissue expression, especially in places
that are known to drive EGFR toxicities like the skin and the
colon, but it has high and homogeneous expression within
EGFR-responsive tumor types. Not only do we see that we have high
expression within the tumors, but we have co-expression with EGFR,
as highlighted here. We partnered an
antibody binding arm of integrin beta 6 with a proprietary
EGFR binder that we discovered. This EGFR binder was
meant to preserve normal EGFR signaling in healthy
tissues.
As you see on here on the left, the molecules that are currently in the
clinic that block EGFR therapeutically also block the
normal signaling in the skin primary keratinocytes.
Our proprietary EGFR binder maintains this signaling, as
does EPI-326.
When we look at the expression of our degrading receptor compared to
other binding arms that have been incorporated into clinical bispecifics,
we see that we have a significant enhancement of expression
within EGFR-responsive tumor types by RNA levels shown here
on the left. We've confirmed this by our own IHC
evaluation, where we see high expression of our
degrading receptor, and again, really good co-expression, over
95% with EGFR in non-small cell lung cancer,
head and neck, and in CRC.
As we've gone on to evaluate the activity of EPI-326, we
started initially by looking at its ability to drive the degradation
and anti-tumor activity agnostic to the mutational status of
EGFR. So what we see here are the classical mutations
that are known to drive
tumor genesis in non-small cell lung cancer.
So exon 19 deletion, the L858R mutation,
as well as resistance mutations that arise upon second
generation and third generation TKI treatment.
So C797S as well as T790M. In
all cases, we see strong anti-tumor activity and
true tumor regressions, meaning that we're actually killing the tumor cells.
We're not just driving them into a static form.
And this is likely due to the fact that we are degrading EGFR and the
scaffolding activity that it
supportsWe've also gone on
to look at how deep of activity we can drive with EPI-326,
as well as to understand if there are potential resistance mutations
or resistances that can arise upon treatment.
So here we're dosing for 40 days, and what we saw is that we were able to drive a
90% CR rate after three doses of
EPI-326. We're able to maintain these tumors in the
CR status for over 40 days, and then after we stop
treating, we actually see that we get a really nice survival benefit that lasted
out for 80 days.
This is pretty hard for a monoclonal antibody to drive deep CR
activity, and we are really excited about the data that we're seeing with
EPI-326.
So in addition to looking at mutantous non-small cell lung cancer, we
also wanted to be able to drive strong activity within
the wild type overexpressed mutant forms.
So here we're looking at CDXs and PDXs from head and neck, as
well as CRC. And what we see is that we're still able to drive
really strong anti-tumor activity, again, true tumor
regressions in these wild type models as well, really
indicating that EPI-326 is able to degrade EGFR
agnostic to its oncogenic form.
We've compared the activity of our degrader to standard blocking
antibodies, and what we see across multiple different model systems
is our ability that degradation does drive these regressions, where
blockade really only results in tumor stasis and then a strong
outgrowth. And this is, again, something that the field for targeted protein
degradation has highlighted is the ability to drive degradation can be
more potent, and we're seeing that with our EpiTac approach.
So in addition to showing really strong monotherapy activity,
because as in a moment I will show you, we have really good safety, we should
also be able to combine within the frontline setting.
So we've looked at this in two different formats.
One is to understand the combination opportunity within non-small cell lung
cancer in combination with a small molecule TKI inhibitor.
Here we're using osimertinib. And what we see is that while
EPI-326 is able to drive strong anti-tumor activity, it
nicely combines with the TKI here to drive deeper and
longer activity, which we think is important as we think about that frontline
opportunity. Additionally, we've been looking at the ability to combine
EPI-326 with KRAS inhibitors within CRC.
What we see here is that we're able to drive to complete responses
within the combination setting. So here, the sotorasib
has limited activity, EPI-326 has activity, but when we
combine them, we're getting these really deep anti-tumor activity in
PDX model systems.
So of course, the important thing is that we're doing this through degradation.
So we've been able to monitor degradation in two ways.
One is through IHC, where we see that 72 hours after
a single dose of EPI-326, we drive almost complete
removal of EGFR off the surface of these tumors.
Additionally, we've monitored this by Western blot, where we gave a single dose of
EPI-326 and then looked for over a week at the level of
degradation that we could drive. What we saw is that EPI-326 was
able to drive over 90% removal of EGFR from these
tumors, and a single dose of activity lasted out for a
week. We actually stopped the experiment after a week, because we thought we might
see some rebound in EGFR, and we don't.
So the PD effects were actually even longer than seven days.
So in addition to looking directly at the removal of EGFR, we've
also looked at the opportunity of EPI-326 to remove the scaffolding
activity. What we see here on the left in vitro is
that we're able to significantly reduce the oncogenic form of
EGFR, so that phosphorylated form, more profoundly than the
blocking antibodies that are currently in the clinic.
Additionally, we have a strong impact on the heterodimer partners
here, shown as phospho-Her3, as well as the terminal
signaling events that happen from EGFR c-Jun.
We see these same scaffolding impacts in vivo in tumor
model systems, as shown here on the right, where EPI-326
treatment results in a significant downregulation of
c-Jun as well as phospho-Her3. I think
highlighting that we're able to take the concepts of intracellular
TPD, where the scaffolding is able to be removed through degradation, and
apply that to extracellular targets and our bispecific antibody approach.
So we've been in IND-enabling studies, and what we've seen is
in addition to the strong anti-tumor activity that we're able to drive with
EPI-326, we had the safety profile that we were hoping to
build in through the selection of that degrader receptor.
So we've been able to dose up to the maximal feasible dose of
204 mg per kg. We've given EPI-326
every two weeks for three total doses and saw no
EGFR-related toxicities, nor really any toxicities.
Our NOAEL in these models was 204 mg per
kg, which is significantly differentiated from other
EGFR-based therapies. Additionally, we have really
nice exposure that is beyond what other
monoclonal antibodies have been able to show within the non-human primate
system.
Based upon our preclinical data, we have strong activity at doses
as low as five mg per kg. So this allows us to go
into the clinic with a really nice therapeutic index, thinking that we'll
be able to start at what we think is a minimally efficacious dose.
So in summary, we believe we created something really distinct with
EPI-326. It's able to degrade all oncogenic forms of
EGFR and do this really safely.We're excited about the
opportunity to head into the clinic as we think about being able to develop in
non-small cell lung cancer, as well as head and neck, and potentially
CRC. I'm happy to announce that EPI-326 is in the
clinic and that we've been able to dose our first patient.
So with that, I'd like to thank the team that has driven EPI-326 to the
clinic. Every member of our team has touched this molecule as it's gone
along. But I'd particularly like to thank John Citron, who is the lead
for EPI-326, Eric Humke, who's going to be moving the molecule
through the clinic, and Ann-Lee Karlin, who helped us complete a
successful Series B raise recently.
We have two additional presentations here really highlighting the opportunity
of the platform for other oncogenic driving targets, and
I welcome you to join the team at the posters.
And with that, I'll take any questions.
Thanks for the great talk. Frank Li from WuXi AppTec.
So you did not show your antibody diagram.
So basically, integrin-6
colocalize with EGFR. So both
non-blocking functionally, right?
You decrease affinity, just bring the degradate
to the complex. So that's the rationale, right?
Yeah.
Because your potency is quite good.
Toxicology dose is very high. So that's your
decreased affinity to EGFR and the
integrin-6. That's the rationale. So how you achieve that, yeah.
Yeah.
ADCC, ADCP also play in the role?
Yeah. It's a
standard bispecific antibody that we have.
The antibody to the integrin beta 6 is non-blocking, as is
the EGFR. So to your point, it's really localizing the
activity to the tumor tissue where both targets are
expressed that allows us to have the activity.
It is a standard IgG1 backbone. It does have ADCC and
ADCP activity, but our degradation, as we've monitored it in
vitro, has no impact through the FC domain.
Okay, thank you.
Yeah.
Hi, really exciting work. This is Alice Berger from Fred Hutch Cancer Center.
My question is about your toxicity data, which looks really great.
I'm wondering about the affinity for the antibodies in
the primate system and also the expression of the targets.
Do you know if they're similar in the non-human primate
system as humans?
Such a great question. Yes. I forgot to mention that.
Yes, the affinity of our antibodies for both arms is the same for
human and cyno, and we've also assessed the expression of
both. EGFR is well known, but our degrading receptor within the cyno has very
similar expression as human. So we think it's very emblematic of what we'll see
in humans.
Great. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
Hi. Very nice talk.
I have a question around MAP kinase signaling pathway.
And have you checked the levels of inhibition of MAP kinase
signaling pathway? That's number one.
And number two would be,
have you checked the expression levels of integrin beta 6
in other healthy tissues apart from skin?
Yeah. So we also looked at other MAPK signaling.
So ERK, we see that that's also affected with our
treatment. And then we did look in the cyno
as well as human for expression within healthy tissue.
It's fairly well known that it has very limited expression in healthy
tissue. Primarily, the kidney is one of the places that you can see it expressed.
Thanks.
Thank you for your awesome presentation. I'm from the SKem in Korea.
So I'm very impressive for the degradation of the EGFR for
seven days. So I'm wondering how caused to
the long term of the degradation of EGFR.
Antibody keep contacting or just the feature
of the EGFR,
the translational feature?
Are you asking how long we have expression of the
degrading receptor? And if the-
I mean, is the
seven days of the degradation of EGFR. Makes sense.
But what do you think, what caused the degradation of the
EGFR?
Is that going to work in humans that way, too?
Oh, yeah. It's a good question. We'll see.
We're going to be taking on-treatment biopsies in the clinic, so we'll understand
if the mechanism translates. But we've seen in multiple experiments
that long-lived activity that we showed, and so I think it's
because the antibody is there. And we have a catalytic nature to our Epitac
approach. The degrading receptor is able to recycle, so it's able to be
processive. And so that's partly why we're getting the really nice,
deep, long-term PD activity we are.
Okay. Thank you.
Mm-hmm.
In the center.
My understanding is that actually many tumors don't rely on the
EGFR signaling pathway. So if this
is a true thing, actually, then would the
antibody be effective in these
tumors?
Yeah. It's a really interesting question.
So the cancers that are addicted to EGFR, we think that
the degradation is going to be able to drive strong activity.
Those that may not rely so much upon EGFR signaling, it is a standard
antibody, so it does have other properties like ADCC and
ADCP to help with that functionality to enhance
the degradation and impact we see on the signaling events.
My question actually is that you had some nice data showing that
actually when
drugs are blocking the pathway
don't work, but your antibody sometimes works.
So
I understood that actually up to 90% of tumors
might be resistant, but
from your work, it seems that it might be a lower percentage.
Can you estimate?
Yeah, I think that's hard to estimate
necessarily on how much of the percentage of the tumors are
responsive. I think the thing that has limited other EGFR
therapies potentially is the fact that they are dose limited.
So it's known that for cetuximab, if you can keep the C-trough levels high
enough, patients actually respond much better.
But you can't keep those levels high enough because of the dose-limiting
toxicities. And so I think that's confounded some of the understanding
about EGFR-based therapies and the opportunity that they hold is the
toxicity that they can bring.
Thank you.
Yeah.
Over here.
Hi. Thanks for the nice talk.
According to the mechanism of action, do you expect
some TMDD happening? And if that's the case,
would you see it as a concern or something you should deal
with it?
Yeah, that's a great question. So we have done the
non-human primate studies looking at lower doses where you can see TMDD with
other EGFR-based therapies, and we don't.
And that's a design principle that we engineered into the antibody to avoid
that TMDD, both from the EGFR side as well as potentially from the
degraded receptor side.
Thank you.
Yeah. Okay, final question here in the middle.
Oh, thank you. Actually, that's a simple question.
I saw you have ADC in your pipeline.
Do you ever think about developing the bispecific antibody as a bispecific ADC?
Yes. Please come to our poster on cMet.
So yeah, we've definitely thought about being able to combine the power of
degradation with payload delivery because we are driving
internalization with our approach, and that has a more effective
internalization activity. So we're getting really nice data on cMet
and ability to drive to addressing lower cMet levels
with this duality of our approaches.
Thank you.
All right. Let's thank Shyra and all the speakers in the session.